I was getting letters from Taliban and a
couple times they showed up to our house
they were telling me that they're gonna
kill me are they gonna kill a member of
my family are they gonna kidnap my son
interpreters have become a very big
target of the Taliban and al-qaeda
there's been a lot of beheadings of
people that have worked with the West
and if we completely pull out of
Afghanistan and we don't bring these
interpreters back the ones that were
promised an opportunity for a visa in
the United States they're gonna be
killed
u.s. immigration policy has been accused
of being slow complicated and
inefficient but can it also be accused
of abandoning foreign individuals who
have put their lives on the line in
service to America that's exactly what's
happening right now too many Afghan
individuals who have served with the US
military as interpreters they're often
seen as the most crucial element in a
military unit without interpreters the
military could not communicate easily
with the local population however the
job comes at a high price they're
labeled as traitors by the Taliban and
live under constant fear for their lives
if they find me they will kill me like
my name was added to to the Taliban
killers they found my picture and
everything and they knew even when where
I'm living in Kabul like thousands of
other brave Afghan interpreters Janus
risked his life for his love of America
and for his belief that America would
follow through on its promise in order
to recruit folks that were going to be
very highly targeted by the enemy
translators they're the bridge between
the US military and the local population
so in order to recruit them we did so
with the promise that look you do hard
work for the United States of America
you put your life at risk you'll have an
opportunity to come to the United States
because we know doggone well that
they're gonna be targeted both during
operations and after congressman
Kinzinger is an officer in the Air
National Guard and a veteran of Iraq and
Afghanistan he has led the charge in
Congress to amend and extend the afghan
special immigrant visa program which was
initiated in 2009 as an attempt to keep
america's promise to its allies the
well-intentioned program allocates a
limited number of visas a year to Afghan
Nationals seeking refuge as a result of
their service to the United States
government however the program has been
largely inefficient bogged down by
bureaucracy the program can take years
to process an application in the
meantime many interpreters have been
killed while waiting and I thought it
will take a couple months but it took me
two years this is sometimes the result
of big government from 2009 to 2013
7,500 Afghan visas were authorized by
Congress through this program but only
around 2000 were actually issued by the
State Department the State Department
has
bonded to criticism by ramping up
efforts to improve the processing time
so far 2014 has seen a tremendous
increase in the number of visas issued
approximately 2,300 Afghans who worked
for the u.s. received a visa out of 3000
allocated however this program is set to
expire this fall with around six
thousand more applicants left in the
backlog Kinzinger in the State
Department are trying to get Congress to
extend their program for another year
and to raise the annual visa limit so
that more Afghans will have a chance to
seek shelter in the United States I
think a lot of the rejection and a lot
of the lack of processing comes from
very strict requirements and plus the
fact that this is a bureaucratic
government I mean when you deal with big
bureaucracies sometimes people are more
concerned with not wanting to make a
mistake than they are with sometimes
maybe clicking yes to bring somebody
over here so while we do need to have
good background checks and we have to be
cautious about this it's been way too
slow at this point and a lot of
translators have given their lives in
the wait Janus was able to escape that
fate and he moved to Virginia in October
with his wife and two children largely
due to the efforts of army captain Matt
Zeller
during his time as an interpreter Janus
was credited with saving the lives of
five American servicemembers and Zeller
was one of them rounds have been getting
closer their artillery had been getting
closer and closer with every salvo and
so I knew the next one was probably
laying on top of me I just thought oh
this is it I die here now I looked at my
watch 450 in the afternoons like I die
around 450 in the afternoon in April
28th 2008 and I didn't ever get to say
goodbye to my mom or anybody to have
kids and I just I kind of was starting
to make my peace the next thing I
remember is I remember
returning to return fire at this guy and
I felt this body land next to me and
then I turn and I see Janus I look like
who the hell are you because I'm Janis
I'm one of your translators and then I
look just passed it what I see the two
guys drop dead and he I realize he's
just shot and killed these two guys and
they were directly behind me Janus
literally had my back in 2008 Zeller and
the rest of his unit returned to the
United States while Janus stayed behind
and continued his work isn't
Berger in Afghanistan it was the hardest
goodbye I've ever had my life they're
soldiers just like us I felt like I was
leaving a member of my year behind
Zeller promised Janis that he would
bring him to safety in the United States
he eventually succeeded after five long
years of pressuring the State Department
now the two friends are focused on
bringing other interpreters to America
when we talk about who we want the
United States of America people that
were willing to really stand up and
fight for freedom are the kind of people
that we want here anyway